i'm sorry brother
sorry that i brought you into this
i just wanted things to be the way they
used to be
that's my brother will
i could use some help my wife needs this
surgery this is real life how much do
you need 231
how about more
32 million i need an extra man i came to
you for a loan look have i ever gotten
you anything that i couldn't get you out
of
it's time for you to do something for
your family
what can i do you for officer we're just
doing a transfer from the back i'll let
you in in 20 minutes if i get it done
real quick promise not to rob the place
all right okay
okay
let's go d you are all gonna have the
greatest story to tell at dinner tonight
don't shoot a cop
go go go go go
lock everything down
nothing gets out
[Music]
[Music]
i got a cop shot i got to get him to the
hospital i'm gonna need you to help us
why don't you help us we're doing
hostages now
we're not crashing into this ambulance
we got a brother cop on board do you
have empty experience combat three eyes
you're a soldier yeah
we
[Music]
you think you're so tough without guns
no danny relax
i gotta get back to my wife and my son
does your wife know you're out banks
we're not the bad guys we're just the
guys trying to get home
we don't get to walk off into the sunset
well
get your heels out of here now
i'm gonna get you back home little
brother i'm gonna get everybody home
[Music]